this video is sponsored by one of my
personal favorite Services rocket money
more on them after the reaction
[Music]
people citizens of the reject Nation we
are reject merched out today looking
like Kingpin out of the greatest Marvel
series Hawkeye all righty well we have
made our way to episode 4 if you didn't
catch our reactions through episode 1
through three that is up here on the
channel of course how are you guys
enjoying this series you're liking it I
see mixed reviews on social media we got
to watch the first three early we were
watching this in real time with everyone
else maybe just 2 hours ahead John how
are you buttered Like Biscuits G how are
you I get it all right Coy how are you I
don't get it but I'm excited to be
explained it later I was lying to him
all righty guys we'll leave a like on
this video that would mean a lot also be
sure to subscribe click that
notification Bell of course cuz we got
one more episode to get through thank
you to prepper for helping us set it
down these highlights and thank you to
all who have already joined us at our
patreon page I'm assuming so I'm time
traveling here that's where you get the
full length Reaction watch along where
you sync up with your own copy of echo
available for super sex Rejects and of
course we cover several things
exclusively over there with highlights
and watch alongs included I'm ready to
check this out I'm excited let's do it
[Music]
guys I sense New York flashback does
anyone else I hear horns of New
York walking here
yep oh going back to Avengers nope take
it back going back to Iron
Man oh it's the opening trailer scene hi
what are you
having huh what are you
saying I don't read pointing to things
I'm going to be really uncomfortable
about it one use your words ouch
dude
she's W I love him pretty things this
guy being such a bully they're so nice
in New York
known for you mean to tell me you can't
read that much body
language wait here Maya uncle has
something he needs to do I need to go
smash this
guy come here
yes ooh crush his head with some frozen
treats I like how he gets her in the
alley so she can't see it but he's doing
it he needs it
nice there you go there you go get some
blood Splat on that
white oh
yeah come on show us Marvel this guy's
going to beat up Spider-Man so
good yeah am blood blood give me it
that's seled wetly it is squelch
intensifies inch your way to feeling
like the Netflix yes punch by punch need
a new jacket I don't want
my
uhoh can I do
that teach
me don't be
afraid I love
you I don't know if this was the
reaction with should have all felt but
certainly
did interesting it really feels like the
early 2000s movies like Daredevil like
Ben affle to your final lesson well
we'll still have our our Sunday evening
dinners but your tutelage has come to an
end you're ready you're a man now for
what to move from the theoretical to the
Practical oh man this really feels like
Kingpin I love the way he like the clip
of his voice we are the only one once we
can trust that's your final lesson okay
okay you're
dismissed this looks and feels straight
out of the Netflix show these scenes
whenever in the penthouse Suites and
stuff yeah just the way the camera moves
and the soundtracks buddy oh is she
about to get taken out what no oh oh The
Interpreter yeah wow she did too much
it's messed up Maya wow now I don't know
what you're saying we could no longer
communicate I did not think this through
Maya I'm just going to have to kill a
lot of
inter maybe that's why he learned before
the Hawkeye appearance cuz he's like I
don't trust interprets I'm going have to
learn could be maybe there will be an
actual story behind
that like a
cyclops he just wants a hug he didn't
show up alone
uh whoa what are we doing a
contact oh so they can communicate
please talk that's awesome that should
be invented if it hasn't
been what yes that's neat I commissioned
a few accessories so I wouldn't have to
learn I thought it was important that we
could communicate with no go between I
killed so many
interpreters de yes you made that very
clear in New York a few years ago this
would have been goofy but you know that
we can actually develop some [__] like
this now oh yeah like we're probably
just a few years away the Apple lens
thing will probably have something
similar I thought that we could have a
Sunday family dinner like we used to
I love this a picnic here in the
yard semantics tomato
tomato potato
potato this was supposed to be Eight
Episodes originally right really I think
it supposed to be more than five yeah I
would have assumed six but I could I
could feel that it was really should
have dived a little more deep into the
backstory not angry with you Maya
despite oh the little souvenir you left
me with didn't look that bad but you did
what you thought you had to just like I
taught you and I was impressed this was
another test I think there's a part of
you that's happy that I'm still
alive but your face it told another
story just now when you saw me I like
how you hear a little bit of the audio
it hurts that you were so ready to
believe the worst you raised a hand to
me in
violence the
hand I thought you saw my actions as
heroic it's good see work always had
your back even then I couldn't stand
when you would get
hurt look at my scar he looks so cool
that hasn't
changed who do I trust they should
create some VR experience just watching
this through the Echoes
POV you have to level with her about
your
dad oh damn it that's
mean I like the Simplicity of this
seamwork
here the emphasis on what happened to
the
Lett cookies from the Bain are they
still your
favorite good no but yeah let's hope
those don't go the way of the
wine this is the best scene out of the
whole series it's just he's got so much
presence to him
always
yes great
[Laughter]
timing I feel like this is when I feel
the most of her body language more of
the Nuance can't
refuse I have a proposition you want an
Empire you'll have it why you can have
everything all you have to do is come
home with me I love when they choose to
use the timing of it is always
interesting cuz it's a connection it's
like an intimacy I think we feel more
for her cuz we were like in her head in
so many ways I'm leaving to New York
this weekend until then I'm at the Chaka
Casino
no I like the complexity of that scene a
lot because I believe what he's saying
and she fears for her life well and yeah
just the conflict of like I've chosen
and I made a fresh choice to reject this
but also the parts that must be holding
on still dinner all the threats of
violence with the trust it's very
interesting he's handing me Queen pin
please tell me you're not that
stupid I know you can that that's what
scares me I would love it if she becomes
a villain she's going to be Shan Chi's
sister with the 10 Rings you know why
I'm 45 and alone because every I cared
about was taken away by him bucket of
blood to your left after your father
died I tried to get out who is this guy
he is so good dude Fisk threaten to kill
me I came back here and did his dirty
work and I don't want you to become me
he's so good at emoting with his hands
and mouth and Body Language it's like
three different acting
skills was
confused this another really good scene
of character work this is like a million
years better than freaking
secret oh yeah oh 100 think this Marvel
show it is really good yeah I just I
don't agree with a lot of parts I agree
with but I don't feel like what I agree
with outweighs what I really like yeah
it has flaws certainly but they're this
big compared to I think the good pass me
one of those bulbs would you sure
F oh so she's really connected to her
ancestors cuz she seems at peace with
it I am wondering if this will
seamlessly blend
though Spirits are calling
out through
generations come on M stay with
me cool great cut cuz the grandma before
the uh woman died at the beginning of
the first episode you know she was
talking about how ancestors are speaking
to me and I feel like it was probably a
very literal thing yeah I think it's a
direct line to her but she's more
connected because of how closer she was
right cuz she'd be like three
generations
away one more reunion there's something
going on Chola can help you and I think
her performance this episode is great
yeah whoever directed this one directed
the characters so much more
interestingly yeah I think she's great
here she's got so much going on behind
her like Stony facade it feels
weighted the dream
catcher do you only thing I'm worried
about is I saw the run time was really
small than the last episode oh no this
is really good so far I know this
episode's pretty great to
me in your head Z
[Music]
are places your spirit has been
to Cosmic dust passed down to
you people playing a game that reminds
me of quiddit
w i saw when I was in high school
you describing I love the wide-eyed like
fear
spectacle oh I gave birth oh wow your
mother doctors at the hospital found
complications as my
pregnancy we were both in
danger it's in God's hands they said oh
whoa oh that's her I found me took me
out at a white Hospital brought me to a
midwife sure where I could be surrounded
by my sisters I knew I couldn't trust
Kaiser permanent ever they rejected my
PO d That's you
damn oh nice cool it's cool the shape
comes into
formations
[Music]
Neo it's like its own sort of ancestral
plane I could hardly say they were
always with
me they had an ability to know when they
were truly
needed like when chloroform is about to
reach on of Maya's mouth yeah that night
with your mother and I it was a life
death or deal
[Music]
sure wow
wowe who came into this squ and said
about lifting the pain of others this is
the most epic birth I've ever seen
TR she was a
Healer
mother when your mother was
killed
a I
see uh not you your father
father
from the father has his perspective so
much
like I
think Generations are
echoing
no is your name theyve been like backto
back really good characters I know three
a banger
episode time would
be
yeah instead she got a
Kingpin nature versus nurture I was
going to say that nature nurtur is real
in this
episode
your whoa you could hear her I wonder if
they turn the mics up a lot of her
scenes for that so good in this epe
different but it's so different she's so
she's great the build of the character
and I feel like if they consistently
ground the mysticism into like the
Heritage and the emotionality of the
characters and her being an anchor to it
cuz i' I've been consistently worried
like how are they going to blend like
stre [__] with no she's about to bust
out the 10 rings and the bangle and all
sorts of other
stuff but it is interesting how the
night before she gets the offer to be
Queen pin and then the morning she
learns the truth about her
ancestry it's a to
pre dichotomy Co it is
[Music]
great song poll am I totally missing why
there's prob people like bashing on the
show if I can really see it and I'm
having like the hardest time it's people
are looking really good man I think so
it's gotten better like each episode
yeah I'd say there's something here to
fix Pok truck everything the light
touches is yours Ain that from Lion
King biscuits knows is Disney all right
cha always says there's nothing too
broke to fix if you want it bad enough
don't throw it away a beautiful
metaphor look damage cars echoing
throughout the
lot cuz we're all damaged and the
traumatic you know Heritage passed down
from the death of the American Auto
industry you know
oh she's going to have the coolest super
suit and also the background and the the
journeys that her relatives have gone on
affect her origin very much so and
sporting characters are so much more
interesting because of that they're
actually related oh that's so cool it is
a
tapestry Maya we are playing black
[Music]
jack come play craps with they all four
oh my God he is Robert DeNiro from
killers of the flower Moon yeah I was
going to say just move in here you know
buy a steak take the profits I suspect
you've come to kill me again she got a
gun pointed yep the other eye I suspect
this weapon aimed at me is to shoot
me I can't remember a time when I
haven't loved you like a daughter don't
you
remember oof you knew what you were part
of at every turn all the people you
killed for me did you plead for their
lives she influenced when she was a
child I ask
you who's the monster but he's always
thought of himself as someone doing the
right thing so he would see it that
way this is 100% a sequel to D cuz we
don't care about that other king that's
what tyrants
[Music]
do pointed that out so much it's
glaring where her whole family learned
for her he was negligent to even try I
was there for
you I know now that I failed you I keep
this with me it's to remind myself where
I come
from oh yeah what's going is it going to
be a head is it a shrunken head GTH
Pal's head no it'll be it'll be the guy
from Reacher's head pass on to
you ah the hammer that killed the dad
there you go my father felt stronger
when he beat my mother do you feel like
a Mayon I got strong enough to stop him
with
that Netflix is
[Laughter]
getting
I was raised by you and then you killed
my dad I killed him to be free to move
forward in my life what are you offering
right now so enough games kill
me here free yourself go ahead wow
manipulative
tactic do it
yourself
stop taking orders you and I
Maya come full circle he knew she
wouldn't in the morning come home just
sometimes there's like that one little
is in the editing I think like the whole
scene was great up until after like the
little a little tiny beat after I'm like
oh this should just I know it sounds ni
I feel the suspense being trimmed
shorter yeah but then after she puts the
hammer down like all right moving along
God damn was great only got five
episodes got to move it
along yeah sometimes there's like little
editing
things oh that's the deleted scene from
Hawkeye it's
Canon that laugh too uhoh the
conflict where's you laying in all these
flashbacks huh yeah where her her
macaroni
is this the first we've heard her score
this is her score sounds like an echo
theme what gave you that idea I don't
know it feels like a superhero like
theme building I think it's just just
cool music just composed music for the
show I'mma call it a
theme I'm sorry Mr Fisk we tailed her
but she's gone
where's she gone slam someone's head
against the jet door yes pick the front
wheel of the jet up and
[Laughter]
Crush dude his lost eye is a superpower
now damn look at that ear hole oh no
there's a earpiece okay I thought he
just had really deep ears
oh sir you broke the plane we're going
to have to switch to a whole new plane
dop dope sauce dope sauce dope sauce we
got some
thoughts then we got one more episode
but I want to appreciate this one in the
meantime because that was best one of
them all I hope five doesn't ruin it
with its really short runtime like
Disney Plus usually does but before we
start talking about that I did want to
share with you guys how Wilson Fisk
managed to get all his finances in order
to maintain such great wealth over New
York City probably with the help of
today's sponsor one that I actually use
and has really helped me out with tax
season so please give it a listen and
support the channel by uh getting
yourself some rocket money thank you to
Rocket money for sponsoring this video a
brand that I am happy to be partnered
with thrilled to it's fortunately one
that I have been using for quite a while
now prior to ever agreeing to a
partnership with them I was like that
makes for the best kind of synergy
promotion because I can actually talk
about them from my heart here reason
being like many of you guys U like for
years I constantly downloading all kinds
of financial apps that I keep forgetting
to use or I don't really find quite as
beneficial rocket money has been the one
the only one I'm not just saying it is
the only one that I have been able to
consistently use rely on that has been
an absolute game Cher for me on a very
personal note running real rejects is an
absolute privilege however you know like
I stress out about taxes and it's the
beginning of the year and I'm like I'm
trying to be smarter and get it all done
now I already started like a couple
months ago getting things in order
managing real rejects finances while
managing my own personal finances has
been an ongoing struggle and I'm very
big on like efficiency and being
organized but clearly wasn't as good
enough as I uh thought I had been so
before rocket money came into my life I
was drowning in subscription and
struggling to keep track of my expenses
and as I really wanted to like get
everything in order rocket money came at
the right time for me I was overwhelmed
with subscriptions I didn't even know I
had or had still been subscribed to I
mean do you ever wonder how many
subscriptions you actually pay for have
you ever taking the time to really do it
it could be a little daunting rocket
money helped me see what I was missing
and best part they even cancelled those
subscriptions for me with just a simple
tap so with rocket money you can have
all your subscriptions in one place
making it easy to cancel anything
unnecessary are without the hassle of
dealing with customer service my is so
annoying plus they'll work on getting
you refunds and negotiate lower bills
saving you up to 20% you just snap a
pick of your bill and let Rocky money
take care of the rest let me just
summarize for you really quick what they
are they're a personal finance app that
findes and cancels unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps lower your bills with over 5
million users and over $500 million in
cancel subscriptions they've already
saved members an average of $720 a year
they helped save me a little bit more
than that don't waste your hard earn
money on unused subscriptions cancel
them today at Rocket money.com rejects
that's rocket money.com rejects if You'
heard other people talk about them well
use ours Rocky money.com rejects cuz if
you use that promo code rejects you
unlock special benefits and yes using
them is also a great way to support the
channel same time it's just a great way
to support your bank account cuz I
cannot stress enough just how much this
app has changed the game for me take
control of your finances with rocket
money and enjoy Financial Peace of Mind
all righty all righty well since John I
got to give it to John he kept pointing
something out that I did not read into
that I was like I don't know why he's
harping on this so much
about why didn't he learn it had to
happen sometime in life I think in one
of that even the reaction highlights I
think I like even cut out one one of
them like we need to keep the rhythm
going he keeps harping on this thing but
a cut God damn he totally like there was
such an emphasis and it was so important
to the character here about the sign
language of him not learning how to
speak sign and I thought it was just
kind of a like a detail that I agreed
with but I didn't think the show took
note of it in any way yeah of him not
learning it seemed like an oversight so
John please you take away the thoughts
first we do have to film five so you
know you don't be a miraculously
efficient I I I love when shows uh I
love when something can put a detail in
there that uh you know it rides on your
patience but yeah that that you think is
just an oversight or a flaw and then
actually becomes an intentional choice I
think that's a good example in a
universe that's been kind of marred
Lately by lack of uh consistency and and
within project foresight uh like that's
a beautiful example of that and this
episode across the board I I mean you've
said it throughout the whole thing like
the scene workor the character beats and
just the Nuance that we got to explore
was really affecting and really lovely
my apprehension about this whole
experience is that yeah it it it doesn't
feel like it was cut up in a blender
however it does feel like certain things
were probably expanded in the 5 to 10
whatever that Original Episode count was
supposed to be it feels like there was
probably a lot more time allowed to
breathe within this world so I feel like
in hindsight four episodes now feels
like we've gotten kind of like one major
scene or sequence or beat or something
with every major part of the greater
Ensemble uh you know her her friends her
family those people it feels like
everybody got like an episode to do a
thing or have an impactful moment yeah
um and so yeah I'm I'm a little worried
about the totality but I think across
the board the show is demonstrated
terrific work and this uh did a really
nice job to me of representing how
lovely it can be when you integrate
culture and you know new kinds of faces
and voices into popular uh popular media
like this because this is doing it to me
in a way that doesn't feel like it's
been tacked on or like it's been Studio
noted or like it's pandering it just
feels like part of the DNA of the show
and I would just love to see it
especially like you know in a world
where reservation dogs exists and where
this kind of borrows uh you know
qualities of that show and clearly
demonstrates that it can embody them you
know like I would love to I would
happily watch more of that but I think
what we've gotten is uh is quite solid
and speaks to a lot of great talent on
display across the board in front of and
behind the camera absolutely absolutely
coryon I got upload a video here um so
why don't you start talking about your
thought why don't you start talking umir
lot what John said I agree that it's an
ensemble piece in front and behind the
camera especially with it being a more
nuanced show and I think maybe that's
why I think we we all mentioned a couple
times during this episode because this
is the first we're filming in real time
uh we did get to to review the the first
three a little earlier but this is the
first since we've seen some other
people's reactions we were we were
blessed to watch the other in a void
which is always nice cuz I don't like
other people's opinions uh to to cloud
my own or just generally I just don't
generally care for other people's opin
well it's just like it I think Marvel
has become synonymous with CR
critical critical thinking implies a
positive whatever the opposite of
critical thinking is either you're
blindly in love with it or blindly
hating it and that's really really
dangerous because it is regardless of it
being comparatively smaller in scale it
is still a behemoth of Pop Culture it's
not doing the numbers it was but it's
still like when you look at the top 10
worldwide box office film for 2023 three
were comic movies 30% to this day is
still a foundational part of Pop Culture
so I know everyone wants to talk about
the bubble bursting because it's popular
to do and I know everybody wants to
complain because it's also very popular
but it is still dangerous to have
something as prevalent in pop culture to
have a knee-jerk reaction to knee-jerk
love something without seeing it or
kneejerk hate something without seeing
it defeats the purpose of art like art
is about the experience so I had a
really interesting time watching this
episode because this is the first one
that was tainted by people and I really
don't understand a lot of people's
perspective on the show oh thank God I
was like where are the hell is he going
with I cired back damn he is just going
and going I thought you might need time
with the upload and now you're like oh
now it makes sense Vanessa I was
listening to every word the White Rabbit
I was getting I was Kingpin monologuing
I've returned but no I I think it's
interesting to watch something through
the lens of having the blind experience
of something like we used to with art
versus watching something with anyone's
perspective and I immediately found
because I'd seen the first three with my
own journey and with these guys
perspective all of us enjoying it for
the most part going yeah it's got its
flaws but overall greater good enjoying
it it's a good time I found myself
defending it more this time and that
also felt weird because I think this was
by far its strongest episode and instead
of just being able to go like this is
what I like this is what I like there
was a little voice in the back of my
head going and like [__] that like I
didn't like that I was reactionary to
the to the other world of that
conversation so I think it's really
interesting when you have a bin show
like this how people will perceive it by
the time it's done since you got five
hours at once you're going through the
whole journey how people are going to be
reacting to it online I'm really curious
how people are going to be reacting in
the comments to this how people are
going to be seeing the show through
their own lens versus the pop culture
lens of of the great Twitter sphere of
conversation because that does affect
your viewing so I think this episode was
my favorite but I also think this is the
episode that won't be for a lot of
people really that's interesting because
I feel like Disney did themselves a
disservice by not releasing all five
when the show's clearly designed to be
binged cuzz cuz I think every episode
you get to helps complement the prior
episode I agree so it helps make the
episodes feel more complete because of
the overall narrative they're telling
even these character moments I was
trying to pull it up I would have like
this one earlier in the season what is I
need I need to just get everyone's names
in front of me so there's Maya
obviously Bonnie see this what I mean
there are some things that I feel like
are would have been more flushed out in
in a longer season and I think there are
things that have been dropped I'm
waiting to reserve some of those
potential criticisms depending on how
the next episode goes so in the meantime
because I'm like oh yeah
Bonnie there's so much of this emphasis
on Bonnie and I'm like now at the final
episode yeah and it's just like there's
one episode where it's the Bonnie
episode and now we've moved on it feels
yeah I was like okay cool you guys
things up kind of this was the Chula
episode I'm looking for okay Chula and
then who's who's the guy who runs the
the roller skating ring Oh Black Crow I
think is his name I'm trying to find the
names that's the name of the skate ring
is his name also black crow I think it's
part of because it's like his ownership
like John
find freaking IMDb okay let's call Black
whatever all right so I I do think that
the the actual episode itself one thing
that I loved about it so much was how
this as much as we got like great
moments from Kingpin here uh with his
manipulation tactics as you know oh
watch me be because he is like a violent
he's like we all know him to be this
like violent Kingpin right but he's also
a domestically violent father of sorts
where he can be soft and welcoming and
nurturing but if you he's got that
temper though that if you don't fall in
line he's going to take out his rage
somewhere or on someone and I I like the
way he's Illustrated that way you saw
him as a lover portrayed that way VIA
even though he doesn't like beat Vanessa
or something but he takes it out in
other ways uh he's he you see him as a
lover like that in in the Netflix shows
and here you're seeing this from the
father illustration that I even though
he's called Uncle it's it's definitely
like a fatherdaughter dynamic right and
then uh with and and the way how you got
like scenes with Chula fleshing out the
backstory with uh the Chaka lore and
then wasn't black crow I think it's like
Henry Black Crow or something like Henry
it might be I think it's Henry Henry
yeah I think this the just the bowling
alley black crow but I could be wrong
yeah I don't know we're at odds here but
we should fight it out yes but the
scenes with Henry as well where he is
talking about
how like Ma you see Maya's disdain here
you see Maya's pain as well like there's
so much unresolved pain because I'm
bringing up all the other supporting
characters whereas before this episode I
would feel like I think everyone's great
but I'm really not attached to Maya and
this episode maintained and even
expanded Upon Our supporting characters
and it was the first time where I felt
like it magnified Maya so much like I
felt for the first time out of four
episodes and maybe that's not the best
compliment to give the show for my
subjective viewing experience but this
is what I mean by how it's gotten better
each episode I really felt like this is
the Echo episode even though everyone
else is like phenomenal as always I
really felt endeared and connected to
her and I thought for using an actress
that is act not I want to say using
hiring an actress casting an actress who
is deaf and who has to rely solely on
you know speaking sign language her eyes
her Expressions body language maybe it
was editing maybe it's the specific
scenes or maybe it's actually her acting
this time I don't know what it was but
this particular episode I was like okay
we got three scenes here where one is
with two are with Kingpin one is with
Chula one is with the roller skating
rinkman my favorite superheroes we just
call Skates so you got three distinct
scenes with Maya and each one I did not
feel like was a repetitive performance
from I don't forget her Cox from a lock
with Cox I did not feel it was
repetition I I thought like oh here's
variety here and and each scene I
thought brought different death and I
felt to quote KO the dichotomy of the
situation she's in of now she's
unpacking you know unresolved [__] with
her family she's got this past traumatic
[__] with Kingpin and she's being pulled
in two different directions right now
and I really don't know where this so so
it's credit I don't know how 5 is going
to resolve I don't know what the plot is
ultimately going to lead to but this was
a very character nuanced episode and and
the thing that I have criticize most
about it is the one I felt least
connected to was Maya and this was the
one I really genuinely felt connected to
her so yeah I want to add something to
what you just said because I really I
think you bring up a really good point
with how she's portrayed in this episode
I think there's an element of every like
familial but in a more direct line
mother or father figure in this episode
because the the Father Figure element of
Kingpin is obvious the maternal element
with the grandfa the grandmother is
obvious but I really like that there's
like the the dad that she didn't have
like he seems like the dad of the town
he kind of like runs things and like
Henry seems to be like this paternal
energy to her even though it's not her
father brother almost yeah there's like
an uness but I I think what we saw in
this episode from her is it's the first
time we don't have her being stoic as a
defense mechanism she's consciously
letting her defenses down because she
wants to figure something out as opposed
to pushing one away so I think it's the
first time we've narratively allowed for
Ekko to kind of get to open up those
parts of her acting repertoire like The
Equalizer got to shift a little the
first three episodes The Equalizer was
kind of at like defense stoic and I get
from the character perspective why
that's necessary but I said earlier when
you were talking I think that I would
have liked this episode earlier in the
season it wouldn't have worked from the
storytelling standpoint but I think what
I would would have liked is to have some
scenes of her with her defenses wavering
so we could have seen some of these
elements so I could get those the colors
in the pette of aloa Cox's acting cuz
here is what I loved her the most so in
addition to my earlier rant about just
the general release model what I loved
about this episode was it gave us the
most colors it gave us the most acting
style choices of actors we've already
loved and we we've seen them grow and
this felt like an exponential like wof
as we enter the third act which I really
liked and the thing I am concerned about
I I just can't I can't you can't ask me
just to eliminate it from my brain it's
not the way my my brain operates I don't
think either of our brains operate this
way there is an awareness that of of the
history with Disney Plus shows the
Marvel shows How It Ends How It Ends and
I'm having the hardest time believing
this is really going to stick the
landing I really am because I'm like oh
there's so much left there's so much
left and they're also not known to give
us season twos like Loki and what if are
what if is an anthology show with aight
different little bit of a serial
connection right like it's not it's not
uh dependent on that Loki was the
exception and that took a long time to
get to you know and with this I I I'm
already seeing like okay well clearly
this was underdeveloped I did find
myself at certain points with Kingpin
already feeling like you know they keep
saying how important you know Maya is to
him but I really feel like we should
have seen some like flashbacks I really
feel like we should have got some
history here instead of them just
talking vager about it and it it because
there's there's a F line between you
know actors provide uh writing assuming
the audience like we're going to give
the audience credit and and let them you
know fill in the blank they can extract
the subtext yeah like however I I don't
think that is actually the uh positive
effect I think I think it negatively
affects some of the scenes where they
could have more impact or there could be
more
tension more of a internal debate for
her
if we got those young adult training
scene a scene of her killing someone for
him like in the comics there's so much
like lore between the two of them it
would have been nice I I gave it crap
because it was like flashback lesser
flashback modern day before the opening
but the rules of Threes I would have
even preferred one more flashback
instead of just to if it was like young
adult before we get to modern day so we
could have had that moment or even just
in that scene of dialogue have a moment
where we see her do something for the
criminal underbelly that kind of like
puts them together as similar before he
full circles yeah I could see like two
versions here where I think it just
maybe needed one more episode think I
know we haven't finished it but I'm
already at the point where I'm thinking
one more episode probably would have
helped save this a lot so that way you
get a lot of that additional meat that
you really need like like honestly
seeing Bonnie's name on IMDb just made
me go because there was so much emphasis
on this Bonnie [__] they don't give you
the time it takes to one thing i' I've
learned lately is you learn a
character's name when the show's doing
its job to the utmost it's like you know
if you give us enough couple of moments
to connect to them we'll remember their
name and I feel like I like everybody
here but they haven't really just given
enough to connect to the point where you
remember the names and stuff like that
and with
Kingpin uh uh oh I totally had something
and and now it's it's floated way out of
my mind because I open the computer it
was the opening of the episode watch
along public for I am
multitasking episode I I actually was
kind of frustrated by that and I thought
that while the alleyway flashback is
striking the way that moment is handled
was pretty was pretty muddy because like
there should be some kind of a a bit of
a conflict nature to the punch of like
when she comes in the alley and kicks
the dude and like Kingpin has that
response of like oh [__] you saw that
but like there's there's a lot in that
moment and you guys commented on that
feeling like it was like a '90s
Daredevil movie kind of experience at
that point and I think that is because
it's like it's undercut where there
should be FL like we should see the
conflict of her being indoctrinated as a
child into this life she says that thing
later about like you isolated me and you
you know essentially brainwashed me into
this life you just gave me a huge
Epiphany in My overall experience of
comic book films John what's that '90s
and 2000s comic book films showed us
scenes from Comics because they knew
that comic fans would connect to him
they knew audience would get just enough
to move on and that's what this was
that's why it felt like it it was like
let's show them as when she was young
cuz that audience will understand new
comic Stuff shows us like regular movies
where it gives us an emotional scene
based on the character that happened to
be named the comic book characters and
that's why you've got things like Dark
Knight you've got things like Logan that
are just Standalone movies because
they're acting and then there's moments
of iconography but when you've got
something that feels like ' 90s or 2000
it'll just show the shot and it won't do
the followup it doesn't give you the day
num Ma and I think that's why I like the
Sony movies because sometimes there's
that well sometimes I'm like I just want
to have the fun and not the you know I
want to I sometimes my steak needs to be
from outb well that's where the
disappointment of some of these little
like sometimes we'll know and it's
probably it's probably things people and
it's it's not inconsistent so much to
the point where it it's like B like you
can have like stretches of the show that
are like 10 minutes long that are like
great and then like they'll just do this
one thing you're like what the rush that
why did you rush that face what just
happened right here reminded me of what
you said because you said there's that
thing of like it's not that the show
isn't giving you stuff to go off of but
there are times where it's important to
show versus trusting like oh yeah we
know what her backstory is from this one
moment we can just fill in the blank cuz
we know the broad strokes and in certain
points that undercuts you like it I
think does here we do have this should
have been the Kingpin in Maya episode
like in the past yeah and I think I
think two episodes really would have
helped yeah like I think a lot
especially when so much of the
hindrances on like you know her getting
in touch with her origin her Roots her
and I I honestly think the the
envelopment of the world with the chalk
top people in present day is so well
done like it just feels a part of the
community naturally and I love that I
don't feel any of those like common band
riverse kind of commentary no it's a lot
like Miss Marvel where it feels like oh
I just get to experience a culture I
think more so than that she's lived in
white breed culture and now she's
learning about her own herited so her
her eyeline is our eyeline in a more
unique way yeah it's a city and and I I
think uh I think but I think the book
ends were great and and I think the per
like the
performances I I remember watching
secret invade man we really do got to
watch next episode I I do remember
watching secret Invasion and feeling as
if I can objectively tell these actors
are doing a great job but I can't feel
for it because everything else is not
working for me yes and here I I could
find myself being very much forgiving of
a moment that doesn't work or something
that's not
but it doesn't undercut like wow the
acting here is so good and then there's
also generally a great sense of mood
there's a great sense of atmosphere the
the the dramatic feels are really felt
like they really let their actors
perform and I I'm very appreciative of
an episode like I don't think there's
any action here right other than the
opening scene really um there's not
really action oh the birth was so we
didn't even talk about the birth scene I
was so emotional I don't even I almost
cried Greg
one day will got to learn to cry some
prune juice for my good for you I need
it I want a thing I don't want I need it
I think all this like Twitter rage is so
constipated emotionally is just another
version of a boy inside who wants to cry
cover your sadness both us know both of
us know this is us ended and I have no
Outlet left stlying came around
abandoned me in my time of need and then
koi immediately begins to weep
Sterling so yeah that's what's happening
with koi
um we out here anyway uh yeah we we got
to watch the next episode and we'll
probably have the longest discussion
there but uh thank you guys so much for
being here uh I don't know what I don't
know if five's going to come out in a
little bit or is this kind of a a
jumbled schedule here done this put us
in a pickle um damn you Disney damn you
for helping us out with watching the
first three early but now not knowing
how to manage my editing tests and
everything else yeah thank you guys so
much and let's send this with a patron
of the day shout
out Danny pancakes you have entered the
era of 2024 where you were now get to
shout out yes and it is January 2024 so
we got to Fathom what your resolution
will be and I think your resolution this
year will to get yourself on on therapy
I think I think you're going to want to
go to therapy Danny look I've gotten to
know you really well see I've talked to
my therapists extensively about you my
therapists constantly like why do you
know so much about this Danny pancakes
guy I'll be like it's not your freaking
business to know why I know if I tell
you you're going to send me to jail I
know exactly how this therapy session
goes down so just know I know some
things about Danny pancakes and Danny
pancakes he needs therapy cuz here's the
thing his legal last name is pancakes
and you know why he changed it to that
cuz the guy can't stop coping with his
depression he he just keeps eating
pancakes B cheating wasn't enough I had
to personify myself as pancake
constantly drowning in pancakes and
syrup because mess because he just
avoids his pain and then what does he do
he works Out hours in the morning to
burn off those pancakes it's a vicious
cycle and he has no time to get to work
it's just eating pancakes and a bunch of
carbs and sugar at night then he gets an
a terrible nice sleep because of all
that sugar and card nightmares and then
he's having to work out in the morning
so go to therapy using betterhelp.com
Rejects and get yourself 10% off in some
deal promo yeah that comes along with it
I don't know yeah a year of therapy for
free don't quote me on that feel like
that's a bunch of [__] it'll fix
your life in one year for free if you
use the promo code perform brain surgery
on you if you use a promo code yeah any
medical procedure you need with our
promo code for the next 365 days you can
get all right Danny well take some Fiber
man because you got to poop those
pancakes
[Music]
out